joining us now with reaction to the
midterm election chaos so much more
South Carolina Senator Lindsey Graham is
with us Lindsey I'm what I'm literally
watching this as though as the world is
and we go from 57,000 I'll read it to
you than 38,000 then 30,000 then 21,000
and 15th uh I mean yeah you can't make
this up and well you can't Florida
federal laws are very clear well the law
exists to avoid to avoid this situation
you want to account for the vote 30
minutes after the election every 45
minutes there's been 90 over 90,000
votes come in after the close of voting
in clear violation of Florida law it's
designed to prevent this situation
Broward County is a national joke when
it comes to elections and here's where
Cavanaugh has a lot in common when it
comes to counting votes and confirming
judges
there's nothing Democrats won't do to
win they tried to destroy Brett
Kavanaugh it didn't work they're trying
to steal this election it's not going to
work and I can't wait to get back to
work and make sure we put men and women
on the judiciary who actually follow the
law the law means nothing delivered in
crassus all about outcome and they're
not going to win a story Cavanaugh and
they're not gonna screw rick scott
senator hillary cheated Bernie Sanders
out of the nomination that mark Elias is
her attorney now think about this he's
the one involved the money fundal
funneled through a law firm I would I
would argue that we should investigate
if that's a campaign finance violation
funneled through a law firm labeled as a
legal expense but it wasn't it was then
used to hire fusion GPS this is the same
mark Elias then of course that leads to
the Russian da see the Russian dossier
is disseminated leaked its contents
before the 2016 election why because
they wanted to steal that election by
misinforming and propagandizing the
American people same players same
character same MO same objective win by
any means necessary well look at Brett
Cavanaugh they tried to deny him a place
on the court but by being deceitful
withholding information from the
committee
ambushing him changing the legal
standard you're guilty until proven
innocent what are they doing a Broward
County they're taking Florida law and
turning it upside down to get a result
this liberal activist lawyer the Clinton
lawyer went to Florida with the purpose
of winning the election well the
election was held on Tuesday you know
Bill Nelson was running not the lawyer
Rick Scott won fair and square what's
going on in Broward County is not fair
and it's not square and we're going to
get to the bottom of it Rick is going to
win but please remember this about 2018
the 2018 cycle is going to be remembered
for liberal Democrats doing whatever it
takes when it comes to judges and votes
to win the law be damned in the eyes of
Liberal Democrats the law is just
something to get around when it comes to
winning what you want remember a judge
found that Snipes had violated state and
federal law that was the Debbie
wasserman-schultz recount
she just destroyed the balance right
illegally she's not updating everything
every 45 minutes which he's supposed to
do she didn't work she didn't give an
accurate number 30 minutes all the other
counties in Florida including the
Panhandle did I just if we if this is
not stopped there's no stopping the
level of cheating that will go on will
be unprecedented
yeah incompetent and deceitful it's no
way to go through life but if the shoe
were on the other foot and this was a
Republican Hill County hopping in County
they're good along us alive right now
yeah meat is ignoring all right senator
thank you we appreciate